bad where the case that his sons or
daughters would go outside and just get
screwed up nuts well maybe that's also
because that was a norm back then so it
was in another time they would sit yeah
like
yeah basically society society as it is
today has changed and moved away from
the point where you could you could
raise a child in a single parent
household and it'll be fine but today
today's day well it wouldn't be a single
parent household then he they would
still have the father yeah they would
still have someone to look like i grew
up in with a dad that was gone a lot
because he was building a business
and we like we're all pr we're all good
you guys met my family they're chilling
yeah yeah like oh that was my whole
point yeah if you take it back even to
the medieval era and and you know uh
egyptians and the persians and the the
babylonians and the medieval europeans
the fathers were off on war campaigns
for years at a time
most of them died in those wars and
never returned and yet the society of
western civilization didn't collapse
into some chaotic uh you know uh hell
hole
so i don't know if this concept of this
this to me this is a creation of of
probably the 50s sort of american
you know
father and a mother and a daughter and a
son and a dog and a white picket fence
that is not a norm i think i think i
think here's the difference and this
goes back to you asking okay one guy who
has 17 kids he can't be there for all of
them i completely agree the difference
of today compared to back then was back
then we were raised in communities
so your whole family were around you so
even if your father wasn't there your
uncle would be a father figure your
grandfather would be a father figure you
would have
your family members
around you even if your actual
biological father wasn't there you would
still have if we're talking about the
male the male fear you would still have
male figures however nowadays because of
technology like you know like my family
are from nigeria like some of us are
here some of us are there some of us in
the state and people live in people
don't uh they don't have their their
tribes like they used to so i think
that's why nowadays
yes we could do the practice of one man
having several children etc and maybe
that would be okay if we still were
raised in tribal communities where you
had you know they say it takes a village
to raise a child yeah but we don't have
this
i think that's why
that's the difference why i wouldn't
work today and you think do you think in
muslim cultures it works yeah because
they still have because their families
they grew up with their families around
them they still have the village they
guarantee you they
um back then they would for example
separate the the children like for once
the boys hit a certain age they would
spend more time with the men the uncles
the dad
all the men and then the
daughters once they hit a certain age
they will only exclusively spend the
time with the women
that's yeah so someone was always
present though yeah do you guys think
that high value men have the right to
cheat
cause think about it think about it
think about it he works his whole life
right to become a one percent guy
multi-millionaire he's jacked he has
everything why would he settle for one
girl
i'm not arguing it either i'm just
playing devils
are we talking about like that guy who
was big on instagram would you say no no
not andrew tate but there was something
cal calrasian i forgot his name he's
he's oh dan bilzerian that's it someone
like that
private jet
uh he's a successful gambler you know
dabblezer
i don't know who that is but i'll take
your words
yeah i'll i'll do i'll do michael b
jordan
why on earth why would he have one girl
i mean if he's operating like that
then i'll just be wondering okay why
working to that level if that's why okay
fine that's what you do that's what what
that's what's motivating you if it's
maybe you like what you do and
outside of the women
you know if you're working that hard
then that's a different reason you don't
think men work for women
i wouldn't say not all not exclusively
yeah so so the whole right to sleep with
multiple women then have to ask okay
that's the main motivator but then if
you're working hard
similar level you have you have other
reason most men have different reasons
what do you what do you guys think what
do i have the right to cheat
and i'm asking do you at that with a
question do you think that men work for
women to get women
yes i think 100 i think 100 i think men
work to put themselves in a in a
position where they can have sexual
abundance yes yeah it wouldn't i don't
think it is it's very um i think
straight to the point to say men work
for women yeah but like like i want my
man said there's a lot more complex
situations in yes men work so that we
can get the best of everything so we can
get the best house the best car the best
of what we want to get and a byproduct
of that well not a buy product but i'll
buy something of that would be then you
have the best woman as well yeah if
that's the case if it just happens to be
you enjoy what you do or you just happen
to have done something and it's resulted
in you earning a lot of money
and the byproduct of course will be
women but that's the thing i just have
to ask like
if you want to cheat or have multiple
partners and okay what's the main what's
motivating you if it's women okay have
your women okay but if it's another
reason you just happen to have made a
lot of money
and
it's a byproduct is having more options
that's fine that's it it's perfectly
fine for me do you think it's fine
either way
even if he is working so if he's saying
i work hard so i can get a bunch of
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's like i don't know that's what
you want yeah that's your life i want
ten i don't want one more if i want
three so yeah that's that's yeah that's
fine
it's for me it's very easy very black
and white there is only one reason a man
has a ferrari
and it's not because it's so just great
at driving and it's got no it's to get
women that ferrari a porsche these are
literally extensions of a man's mandom
uh this is just i mean these things were
not even would not even be being made if
you think if a ferrari was as popular as
a skoda when it comes to picking up
women men would bother buying people
can't be honest i think that's that's
more the case a woman knows how much a
ferrari costs
as a man as a man
personally there's things that i like
because i like it it doesn't matter how
much it costs i just like it because i
like it yeah and if a woman knows how
much it costs then that's gonna hurt her
like me because how much it costs but i
got it for me i didn't get it
can i be can i could you give me an
example sorry
an example yeah something that you have
that you would deem somewhat expensive
that
you didn't buy for a woman you bought it
for yourself
i can give you my house your house okay
that helps though i'll give you an
example it helps what i'm saying it's a
by-product yeah yeah and at the same
time you get you get a by-product from
it but i didn't get it okay to get a
woman i got it for myself that's what
that's what you have to check like okay
i didn't get the house for something
else
about the ferrari maybe maybe use the
cars by example because i think the
funny thing is i think guys may
initially think oh yeah i'm gonna get
this car to attract women but actually
it just attracts other men
yeah but
because it just makes other guys go yo
man that's a nice car no but you've seen
it you've seen it yeah but how's that
how'd that screenshot work out for you
exactly do you want to tell the story
tell the story you're about to get me in
trouble no story time
okay